the first time I heard of such things
was on a Biggie Smalls album where he
talks about his story where he poops on
a woman's chest
yeah
yeah and then it goes I'm going going
back back to Cali
[Music]
all right we got another awesome article
that has been submitted by one of our
amazing patrons hopefully you're on the
live stream right now which one this is
submitted by Bowzer clone
tree honors right now because they're
watching this live I don't want to rag
on Bowser but I thought we evolved from
like AOL or first like Xbox names
like that's definitely like a 1999
I thought we evolved no I thought we I
thought we sufficated now I think we got
past that yeah I thought we grew up how
come we're gonna go back you're getting
the [__] doing your rice for me all
right so there's a German ballet
director right who got a Critic from a
Critic yeah because he's German ballet
it has to be Russian ballet it was a bad
review and so he got upset so what he
decided to do was he took his dog's [__]
put in a bag and then brought it and
confronted this critic and smeared it in
her face in her face in her face is that
illegal okay I'm gonna pretend like I
didn't hear her
I like what happened because I like it
when people don't hide behind keyboards
but you [__] up the whole story by
making a girl do you think a Critic is
different than an Internet troll though
internet trolls and critics a
professional critic like that's kind of
the same yeah what if she worked for
IMDb or some [__] now is it a little
bit different they're still [__] no
they're like Yelp reviewers if you talk
some [__] no matter who gets like it
could be Charlemagne you could be
whatever the [__] you want expect to get
popped in the face and if that's fair
game then everyone say whatever they
want to say Charlemagne says you don't
like your hair you're rubbing [__] in
his face maybe if I was [__] up dog
[__] if I was Birdman I [__] roll up
in there with like 30 homies
from the movie Birdman Michael Keaton
Birdman
what would somebody have to say to you
for you to go get your dog Mia's [__]
and then rub it in their faces dude
Mia almost [__] on me twice this weekend
she did you must have been a bad kid oh
it goes close how how did she [__] on
you I don't really care when people talk
[__] about me what if they're talking
[__] about your dog's [__] this guy's
pretty bulletproof I think no no I don't
so I don't care that people talk [__]
about me but if I'm viewing the world I
like seeing the fair game so I like
seeing okay someone talks [__] about
Ryan then it's okay for Ryan to punch
you in the face just let you know that's
the rules I saw a man get caca all over
his face because he pooped in front of
somebody's house and he didn't clean it
up so the guy got mad and he picked it
up in a bag and he told him [__] you
human yeah who's human [__] in front of
another human's house and how did he
stick around for that that sounds like
there was a problem at the gym recently
so we had this gym that we work at and
in the back it's like a it's like a like
a duplex or something like that so we
share a gate we all park in the same lot
one night the owner of our gym didn't
lock the gate
and the guy who lived in the back came
out and said hey man like you guys
didn't lock the gate and he was like oh
I'm sorry I thought I left early enough
it was like seven o'clock my bad I
didn't lock the gate totally my fault
and the guy goes yeah the reason why we
lock the gate is because some drunk guys
come behind the dumpster and they take a
big old [__] and it happens very
frequently we're like and we were like
oh my God I'm so sorry he's like I had
to clean it up and he's like and it
happens a lot and we're like oh my God I
am so sorry is there a bar nearby yeah
why is that like a thing there is no bar
nearby so we were like what who is this
it's him yeah no there's the cameras in
the back
it's for sure him though and I had to
clean it up he just [__] his pants you
need to [__] electrocute that
[__] I know but but I guess he
said because his shoes on some Eye For
Eyes no the if you're shooting in
people's [__] duplexes you need to
electrocute them up for a good man
watches Bobby Lee
like why is this happening so pretty and
how's it like clockwork that's
interesting that's why that's the only
reason why we locked the gate and I did
not know that I thought it was for like
for security reasons not just because
that's technically I guess security
right yeah but like not like the fact
that he's he's not stealing [__]
what'd you expect the [__] FBI raids
and narcos to come that kind of security
maybe dude or like homeless people right
because that's a that's a thing yeah
there's not even that many there's like
no homeless people on our block why is
[__] in feces and Kaka the first like
line of defense for [__] talking yeah
your roasted cacao why is that's why
it's called shit's office yeah I guess
but you know what I mean like I think of
like approaching and doing hey man I
heard what you said but I'm not
automatically thinking like
[__] to the face yeah that's that's wild
yeah it's a little wild don't you think
Bart that's your first thought when I
piss you off like how can I get [__] in
this guy's face because imagine like
you're playing basketball right someone
actually fouls you you don't [__] go
yeah that's what I'm saying
I'm also not farting in my hand and
putting in your face what if there's
some kind of loophole that's a lesser
charge than assault oh there probably is
yeah if I punch you I'm going to jail
but if I just put some dookie on you at
school dude that's pretty bad though
yeah
you get pink eye you're throwing up from
E coli because if two people threw down
you're like oh okay whatever they
[__] they didn't see I I like I I
whatever but people are like [__]
pissing and [__] and [__] we just
turned into monkeys
[Music]
like bro [__] can't be that crazy was it
Billy Madison like [__] can't be that
far off that has to be I need to do that
I would way rather you spit on me than
[__] [__] I'd rather you knock me out
punch me in the face don't put dookie on
me the dude the dude that did that in
Hollywood where he dumped a bucket of
his own diarrhea and the lady he was up
he's out of jail that day
there's a correlation with if you're
gonna put [__] on people you better be
[__] homeless you're crazy you know
what this might take that guy's home
away from him if someone brought [__] on
your face and they're successful in it
that person should get death penalty I
think
all in favor
aye yeah and if there's video evidence
penalty yeah or a public vlogging which
which death penalty though
vlog
gy forced splits of course like [__]
uh you want to Wishbone somebody yeah
but what if they're flexible this is a
ballet director
oh yeah that's a bad punishment as a
dude by the way a dude who smeared it on
a chick's face that's crazy yeah in
Germany yeah German ballet stop saying
[__] just say another dude so it was a
shiza do you want me to just make it
easier for you to hear yeah
dude I'm a liberal don't hurt my
feelings like that oh yeah I heard
German King says they like to do
cockaplay a lot that is a what's that
called a fecal porn or scat porn I watch
two girls one cup and it was pretty good
I guess German sex tourists are known to
travel to different countries to get
pooped on and poop on others and what's
it called here Cleveland steamer yeah
nice yeah that's the chest one yeah the
first time I heard of such things was on
a Biggie Smalls album where he talks
about his story where he poops a woman's
chest
yeah
yeah and then it goes I'm going going
back back to Cali no I'm just kidding
it's in that song oh No it's I think
it's the one that's nasty boy you nasty
boy you nasty you know that song yeah so
let's let's try to empathize with this
dude you pretend to be a German ballet
director yeah that's easy he's the
German dude talk about your ballet
please
I have crafted a very good ballet in the
over the past six months
um and there was a critic that wrote a
very nasty review about my ballet and as
I'm saying this I'm like did I lose my
attorney
you you Channel a little bit more Hitler
what happened to my be more Angry yeah
what accent is that you're out there
yeah don't be so you know what no what
was that actually I draw a swastika
under chest yeah go ahead get a Sharpie
put it on my [__] lips okay and this
is this is among some of the things that
the critic had written
um one alternates between a state of
feeling insane and being killed by
boredom and watching the performance
impaired viewing it to uh passively
Washington they're going out of their
wear to be really hard they're saying
behind a glass left to sit in the warm
looking at a winter beach like a
permanent state of retirement did Ryan
write this dude whoa that sounds like a
satirical review yeah yeah
so like that was some deep cut stuff
you're you're a German ballet cars and
this person's dropping [__] poetry on
you damn that's that's kind of hard I
don't know if I've ever been that mad to
throw poop at somebody though and I used
to have a bad temper but I don't think
I've ever thrown poop is crazy this
isn't throwing this is like yeah the
same that's even worse because what's
happened in my hand yeah was she wearing
gloves that's gonna stink for like a
week you're not washing that [__] out
yeah and then once it gets smeared the
smell changes you know what I mean like
it gets deeper it's like when you step
on dog [__] versus just smelling it it's
like re-oxygenates it you know
smeared cold [__] smells different from
hot fresh [__] that's also true too I
could kind of smell it at the dog park
right now because the crust is always a
different scent from the mantle
that's Trudeau
is is uh throwing [__] at someone more
severe or is a bow and arrow or severe
yeah
unless it's poisonous bow and arrow I'd
rather get hit with the bow and arrow to
my face excuse me yeah just like a small
flashlight but if it's like a small pan
like yeah I could do it I don't think I
could deal with knowing that I had [__]
all over my face why don't you just run
away if I see someone running at me like
this
classic [__] smearing right yeah
that's what happened to me in elementary
school yeah you can't run from an arrow
oh you can't run if they run faster than
you I'm fast dog you get tired here yeah
I do get tired I do get tired I do an
endurance racing will catch up for about
a second on real quick but a guy running
with his hand out yeah he can't pump
yeah he can't get the momentum bro
that's one arm don't ever underestimate
a laughing kid with a handful of [__]
there they won't stop that's when a
sidekick to the chest is like they won't
stop that's true and once you fall down
because you're running so fast they come
to your back and smear or if you're like
laughing while running away yeah you
know when you're laughing and trying to
run away and your laughter makes you
weak yeah
the kid has you I know it's over oh
you're dead to right to me I gotta
[__] hit with a [__]
that's terrible yeah she should this
person bow and arrow 100 man it's a
cooler story oh somebody should get the
death penalty it's the guy the guy who
created this terrible music the guy yeah
sleep